the death of an American college student
imprisoned in North Korea is drawing
widespread condemnation on a WOM beard
died in Ohio yesterday at age 22 yes a
popular former high school athlete and
star student was held for more than 17
months he would have graduated in May
from the University of Virginia his
family said in a statement yesterday
quote the awful torturous mistreatment
of our son received at the hands of the
North Koreans ensured that no other
outcome was possible beyond the sad one
we experienced today Margaret Brennan is
at the White House Margaret good morning
good morning well following the tragic
death of otto warmbier the Trump
administration is considering a ban on
American travel to North Korea as US
officials look for new ways to isolate
the rogue regime otto warmbier has just
passed away President Trump said quote a
lot of bad things happen to the 22 year
old Ohio native during his 17 months in
a North Korean prison but at least we
got him home to be with his parents
where they were so happy to see him even
though he was in very tough condition
but he just passed away a little while
ago that's a brutal regime and will be
able to handle it it was just last
Tuesday that the warmbier family saw
their son for the first time since he
was sentenced to 15 years hard labor
he spent the final year of his
imprisonment in a coma
unknown to US officials early this month
North Korea revealed the truth and the
State Department medically evacuated
warmbier to his hometown of Cincinnati
the American doctors who examined
warmbier said he sustained a
catastrophic brain injury shortly after
his conviction escalating tensions
around Kim jong-un's expanding nuclear
program complicated attempts to secure
his release with three other Americans
still imprisoned Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson said the administration may
retaliate former Governor Bill
Richardson who advocated for warm hairs
release argues the US should sanction
North Korea unless
all Americans are released North Korea
should step up realize their huge
mistake do the right thing and send them
home Kenneth BAE one of the few
Americans to survive nearly two years in
captivity released a statement pleading
for the lives of those three Americans
Kim dong-chul Tony Kim and Kim Hawk song
as well as the millions still suffering
under the regime Gayle those June
meetings to discuss bringing warmbier
home represent the first known direct
contact between the Trump administration
and North Korea Margaret thank you